france angleterre une rivalité
millénaire et sanglante
alors même que les deux pays sont
voisins la raison c'est cette mer si
petit et pourtant frontière naturelle et
si vous changez l'histoire et si les
rois de l'ancien temps avait voulu
relier l'île au continent avec la
science et l'ingénierie on va voir si
c'est possible et surtout comment faire
le ton remplir la manche avec de la
terre quand il fait beau depuis les
plages françaises
vous pouvez voir les codes de
l'angleterre elle paraît si proche qu'on
aurait presque envie de les rejoindre à
la nage
c'est exactement ce que font certains
nageurs 2000 ont déjà tenté ce qu'on
appelle l'everest de la natation avec un
record à 7 heures pour traverser les
trente quatre mille mètres de mer il y a
cinq cent mille ans ça aurait été plus
simple puisque vous auriez pu faire le
chemin à pied
l'angleterre était rattachée à la france
par une pente de terre il y avait même
une immense cascade qui devrait offrir
un spectacle incroyable
malheureusement elle a été engloutie et
c'est justement notre projet
d'aujourd'hui reconnecter les deux pays
alors combien de mètres cubes de terre
faudrait-il pour construire ne serait-ce
qu'une route
déjà faut choisir le bon endroit il est
déjà tout trouvé c'est ici où c'est le
bloco le même chemin qu'emprunte le
tunnel sous la manche
on va construire une digue de 34 km de
longueur 30 mètres de largeur et 30
mètres de profondeur en moyenne au total
ça nous fait 30,6 millions de mètres
cubes de matériaux et c'est pas tant que
ça vous voyez ce trou bien c'est la mine
de mire en russie on aurait juste besoin
de 10% tout ça pour faire notre digue
on en a même déjà fait une du genre au
pays bas avec la base nautique
elle mesure 32 km de long 90 m de large
et c'est par la mer des wadden en deux
c'est exactement ça qu'il nous faut sauf
qu'il y a un petit problème la flo
dickner immergé qasim
à trop de profondeur la manche c'est dix
fois plus à certains endroits sans
compter qu'une forme cubique totalement
immergé dans l'eau ne va pas rester bien
longtemps avec les courants toute cette
terre finira par s'effondrer et former
une sorte de pyramide
ça paraît peu mais c'est exponentiel il
faudrait au final 165 millions de mètres
cubes cet équivalent à 64 pyramides où
creuser trois fois la dune du pilat on
est d'accord il vaudrait mieux changer
de méthode et pour ça on peut
s'intéresser à une dit plus moderne la
plus longue du monde
la digue de sao mango 36 m 2 où 34 km de
l'eau et une largeur moyenne de 290 m un
chef-d'oeuvre d'ingénierie pour réussir
cet exploit ils ont usé l'équation d'une
zone qui donne une forme de digues
optimale avec une utilisation de
matériaux résistants l'érosion limitant
donc la pente de la dic
grosso modo construire ça sur la manche
ne demanderait que 64 millions de mètres
cubes de matériaux soit l'équivalent de
la dune du pilat ça reste quand même une
oeuvre pharaonique qui n'auraient pas
été techniquement possible dans l'ancien
temps alors pourquoi ne pas le faire
aujourd'hui parce que ça serait trop
chère ou juste que ça serait un désastre
écologique en dehors de l'extraction de
la terre qui détruiraient des forêts et
de vendre et des milliards de litres
d'essence
ça ferait un véritable mur maritime pour
les poissons amour aussi pour les
bateaux la manche c'est 20% du trafic
mondial
un bateau toutes les trois minutes
même si des passages peuvent être créés
dans la digue pour les laisser passer
le trafic ne pourra plus jamais être le
même ça serait un désastre économique
voilà pourquoi on pourrait penser une
solution plus simple
peut-on construire un pont entre la
france et le royaume uni
c'est le rêve de ben jonson premier
ministre anglais et défenseurs du bar
excite même s'il veut sortir de l'europe
il veut son pont pour pouvoir maintenir
le commerce avec le continent
mais est ce que c'est possible le plus
long pont maritime au monde passe par
hong kong et mesure 55 km pour la manche
il nous faudrait un pont très haut pour
que puisse passer ce genre de bateau
contenait rousset giga croisière en
termes d'ingénierie sur la dizaine de
ponts possible de pourrait remplir ce
rôle
les ponts suspendus et les ponts à
haubans le problème des ponts suspendus
c'est qu'il faudrait des piliers plus
haut que le pont imaginez l'équivalent
d'un giga building en béton armé ultra
lourd au milieu de la mer c'est
compliqué
reste donc le pont à haubans l'humanité
on a déjà construit des titanesque comme
le viaduc de milo 343 mètres de hauteur
est cette enfant ce monsieur sauf qu'un
tel point ça pose d'autres problèmes que
l'ingénieur d'abord les bateaux à cette
place pour pouvoir les faire passer
entre les piliers
mais imaginez les risques de collision
un pétrolier qui se pensaient en pleine
face autant vous dire que ça serait
fatal pour éviter ça chaque pilier
devrait être entouré d'une île
artificielle mais ça nécessite encore
des millions de tonnes de terre qui vont
s'éroder et qui vont finir par bloquer
l'accès des bateaux ensuite le vent un
pont cette instable le golden gate à san
francisco peut se balancer jusqu'à 8
mètres 50
le pire accident du genre s'est produit
au pont tacoma en 1940
regardez ces oscillations elle entre en
résonance et s'amplifie au point de
faire du pont une feuille de papier qui
finit par se briser en trois la
température en hiver la tour eiffel à
cause du froid perd 8 cm en été elle
peut gagner jusqu'à 15 cm sur les faces
exposé au soleil
ouais on était la tour eiffel n'est pas
droite elle est un mouvement circulaire
au sommet c'est ce qu'on appelle
dilatation thermique et ça les points
actuels ont déjà trouvé une solution
les joints de dilatation si vous êtes
conducteur vous êtes déjà passé sur un
pot c'est le petit boss que vous pouvez
ressentir
donc là dessus ce problème on sait déjà
la règle et celui qui sera le plus
difficile c'est sans aucun doute la
profondeur de la mer les fonds marins
doivent être suffisamment solides pour
soutenir les fondations si la tour de
pise ça fait joli
pas sûr que ce soit le cas sur un pont
censé être traversés par des milliers de
voitures chaque jour des solutions
existent comme solidifier les fonds marc
en coulant du béton est plus profond
plus c'est cher et si la profondeur
moyenne est de 30 mètres il ya tout de
même des trous à 70 m s'il est possible
d'en éviter une partie certaines piles
devons quand même y être implantés à
cette profondeur le coût de la pile de
pont serait absolument pharaonique nous
dit un expert déposé chaussée un pont
même s'il est possible ne serait
peut-être pas la solution idéale
alors pourquoi ne pas faire comme le
pont hong kong et macao le plus long
pont maritime du monde eux ont choisi de
creuser un tunnel là où c'est trop
profond
peut-on faire un tunnel pour les
voitures entre la france et l'angleterre
vous le savez depuis 1994 il existe un
tunnel sous la manche
sa construction est un exploit humain il
aura fallu sept ans pour que ces
ouvriers français et anglais puisse
enfin se serrer la main qui cette image
c'est un vieux projet dont beaucoup
d'européens ont rêvé dans l'histoire a
commencé par napoléon bonaparte lui-même
ses successeurs à de même creuset quatre
kilomètres de galeries mais les travaux
ont été stoppés avec le début de la
guerre franco allemande de 1870
le projet est abandonné et les galeries
sont murés à la suite
les ravers ont beau s'être succédé ils
n'en sont restés kaleta des skis ce ça
c'était jusqu'à se bougeront du 1er
décembre 1990 l'europe avait enfin
réussi mais le projet a été rempli
d'embûches
la presse était vigoureusement contre
exaltant les peurs comme elle l'a
toujours fait ça va coûter cher il y
aura du terrorisme il y aura des
accidents et les français vous nous
contaminer avec leur maladie moyenâgeuse
oui oui hein
argument du retour de la rage c'est allé
si loin que la société eurotunnel a dû
diffuser des brochures d'information
avec les vrais chiffres à l'appui le
projet de tunnel était aussi critiqué
parce qu'il avait des concurrents de
nombre d'autres projets très sérieux ont
failli voir le jour un des plus
ingénieux
c'est l'europe qui est un pont mais
aussi un tunnel la circulation devait se
faire sur plusieurs étages un intérieur
permettant un flux plus important qu'un
simple pont verticales
mais le projet a été écarté en raison de
son prix 68 milliards de francs à
l'époque soit 10 milliards d'euros
beaucoup trop cher selon certains
seulement lorsqu'on sait le coût final
du tunnel sous la manche
ça aurait pu être une bonne affaire
parce que si au début on pensait qu'il
allait coûter 29 milliards de francs au
final on est à 100 milliards près de 15
milliards d'euros
al'annonce du choix d'un tunnel le sel
était présent chez les concurrents
notamment euros route qui qualifie ce
choix de médiocres et digne du 19e
siècle
pourtant ça reste une vraie prouesse
technique sur 150 km de tunnels au
moment de la jonction
il y avait seulement deux centimètres de
marge d'erreur vous imaginez-vous devoir
vous située à 75 mètres sous terre
partir exactement dans la bonne
direction
un aveugle si aujourd'hui on est tous
équipés d'un gps
à l'époque les systèmes de localisation
français et anglais étaient très
différents et on n'avait jamais jusque
là réussir à les faire fonctionner
ensemble
aujourd'hui plus de 350 millions de
passagers ont pris le train pour
traverser la manche
parce que oui il n'ya qu'un train
impossible d'y aller en voiture
mais pourquoi avoir fait ce choix alors
non c'est pas parce que les deux pays
roues dans un sens différent on sait
faire des échangeurs pour ça comme entre
ont conquis roule à gauche et la chine à
droite
et puis au pire comme en suède c'est
possible de changer le sens de conduite
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait en 1967
non s'il n'y a pas de tunnel routier
sous la manche c'est probablement
politique déjà la pression des
compagnies maritimes qui prendra un
bateau alors qu'on peut simplement
prendre la route
ceci s'est passé à san francisco où les
lobbys de la mer ont réussi à empêcher
la construction du golden gate pendant
un bon moment
ensuite les compagnies ferroviaires les
billets de trains leur permettant de
faire de gros bénéfices
en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils ont dû
penser parce que dans les faits ils se
sont retrouvés avec une dette de neuf
milliards d'euros qui n'est toujours pas
remboursé en 2021
au delà de la politique il ya quand même
un gros enjeu de sécurité
imaginez un accident au milieu de la
manche des millions de tonnes juste au
dessus de vous dit cette nuit m tunnel
de chaque côté le 11 septembre 2008 on a
d'ailleurs eu une belle frayeur avec un
incendie d'un camion dans le train je
peux vous assurer qu'à 70 mètres sous
terre personne ne vous entendra crier
en tout cas ça n'a pas l'air d'avoir
dérangé cet anglais qui se dit qu'aller
en france à pied par le tunnel bourgoin
se faisait un peu de temps mais bon le
fait pas une grosse amende vous attend
la sortie
j'espère qu'après cette vidéo vous êtes
fier des prouesses humaine que ça vous a
peut-être donné envie de devenir
ingénieur et de rejoindre ce genre de
couronnes aventure architecturale
merci à spike ya ma tarte pour le raid
sur cette vidéo
allez les amis ciao